let's get into this week's hatred mail
what is hatred mail this is hatred mail
brace yourselves for the only
information that can successfully
penetrate a tin foil hats Patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay
alert this week's hatred mail contains
what may be a new slogan for what I
don't know but it may be a new slogan
for something take a listen
David Pakman the cuck starts here this
is fake news unsubscribe all you Jews
are sick David is a beta cuck soy boy
communist [ __ ] as well as his
regressive followers Mexicans and
Muslims here to destroy America you know
what's funny there are quite a few
congressmen that have visible and
audible signs of Alzheimer's dementia
Diane Feinstein Nancy Pelosi Maxine
Waters John Conyers what do they all
have in common
the cuck starts here that is quite a
slogan I don't know for what it's not
gonna be the theme for the David Pakman
show but somebody should use that for
something and he said unsubscribe to
which I believe that he will subscribe
for one point yeah I do want to ask you
though Pat as a vegan you might be
familiar with this term what is the soy
boy there's been a couple times now that
people not just in hatred mail but on
like on YouTube as if they refer to me
as a soy boy yeah I think the Infowars
people and Paul Joseph Watson put out a
video about how soy is bad for your
health
yeah and it's been debunked many times
over and not only that one of the
products that Paul Joseph Watson
advertises for yeah has soy in it Oh
does it really yes what we soy boy do I
guess yeah soy boy I mean I know I know
about the brook from a digestive
standpoint this is hatred Mel we're
talking about digestion of soy I do
believe that I've read some some pretty
good material about it's I think
unfermented soy is not good for women to
have yeah I guess there's the debate
over if it's healthy for men to have
- yeah as it has estrogen but it's plant
based estrogen Jim which doesn't affect
human hormone I mean there's there's a
whole scientific discussion that's
probably beyond hey treatment it's
probably beyond the scope of the cuck
starting here yeah that's for sure
okay anyway I am so boy David Pakman and
I'm here to tell you the cuck starts
here you can use the coupon code patriot
40 this is a weird show you can use the
coupon code hey tree at 40 when you get
a membership at david pakman.com slash
membership it'll save you 40% it's like
a middle finger to the hey treants